مؤمن خان يونس على ما يبدو في الفتره
الاخيره او في الساعات الاخيره كانت هدفا
للقصف وكذلك كانت مسرحا لاشتباكات ربما هي
الاعنف وكذلك هناك في وسط القضاع في دير
البلح وفي غيرها من المناطق اطلعنا على
اخر
التطورات نعم محمود بالفعل خانيونس هي
كانت مسرح للعمليات العسكريه والقصف
الاسرائيلي خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
نتحدث عن اكثر من 40 شهيدا وصلوا الى
مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى الاوروبي هنا في
خانيونس نتيجه تواصل الغارات والقصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي اعنف هذه الغارات هي
غاره جويه اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا لعائله
بريس في مخيم خانيونس اسفرت هذه الغاره عن
ارتقاء 17 شهيدا بينهم 12 طفلا وما زالت
فرق الدفاع المدني تعمل في تلك المنطقه
لانتشال جثامين عدد من المفقودين بين ركام
هذا المنزل الذي دمر على رؤوس ساكنيه دون
سابق انذار بصواريخ جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل ايضا على الصعيد
الميداني تجددت الاشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
عدد من محاور الاشتباك في وسط مدينه
خانيونس بالاضافه الى المحور الشمالي وسط
تحليق مكثف لطائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه
في اجواء المدينه وعلى ارتفاعات منخفضه
كما ان الاليات والدبابات الاسرائيليه
تواصل قصف عدد من المناطق الشرقيه تحديدا
في خزاعه ومعن وبن سهيله والفخار شرقي
المدينه والتي تشهد هي اشتباكات منذ ساعات
مساء امس وحتى هذه اللحظه في مدينه دير
البلح وسط القطاع ارتفعت حصيله الشهداء
نتيجه غاره اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا
لعائله تمراز في شارع البيئه في المدينه
الى ثمانيه شهداء الى ثمانيه شهداء
والحديث يدور عن عدد ايضا من المفقودين
الاخرين بين ركام هذا المنزل بالاضافه الى
وصول عدد من الاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى جل الاصابات وايضا الشهداء في قصف
هذا المنزل هم من النساء والاطفال كما هو
الحال في قصف منزل عائله بريص في خانيونس
ايضا حتى مراكز الايواء التابعه للامم
المتحده والتي من المفترض ان تؤوي وتحمي
النازحين فان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
استهدفت مدرسه تابعه للر في مخيم المغازي
اصفر هذا القصف الاسرائيلي عن استشهاد
اربعه من النازحين بينهم سيده بالاضافه
الى اصابه عدد اخر بجروح متفاوته تمكنت
طواقم الاسعاف من الوصول الى تلك المدرسه
داخل المخيم وانتشال جثامين الشهداء
وانقاذ حياه الجرحى في حين ان هناك عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى وايضا عائلات محاصره سواء
في منطقه الزوايده او داخل مخيم المغازي
والبريج لا تستطيع الخ خروج من منزلها
نتيجه الحصار الذي تضربه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على تلك المناطق التي تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه بين المقاومه وجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في وسط القطاع ايضا
الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه تواصل قصف
ساحل المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا الساحل
الغربي من مدينه دير البلا حيث فتحت
الزوارق الحربيه مساء امس نيران اسلحتها
الرشاشه تجاه ساحل المدينه دون ان يبلغ عن
وقوع اصابات نتيجه القصف من الزوارق
الحربيه الاسرائيليه من الجهه الغربيه
لوسط القطاع